[Music]
you're talking when the teacher said
action
no no i wanted to ask you a question it
feels like i was a kid
you're traumatizing him okay trigger
so uh bart so with taika
right now that you guys are spending a
lot of time
what are you guys doing to keep him
entertained or like educate him
in any sense like do you guys do any
like educational activities together
um not like any structured
activity but it's more like we just play
and when the opportunities arise then we
teach so like let's say
he's like oh come play cars with me and
he wants to put the cars down his slide
then we'll go one two three and then you
know
we'll count up to like 10 and he knows
how to count up to 12 and then it goes
like 12
17 19 20. and then 600
so we got to fill in some of the other
numbers mix it up damn where did you get
600 from
i don't know so yes so yes we have to
fill in some of the other numbers or
he'll be playing and we're like
oh that's your elbow that's your ankle
we were just teaching like more of the
planets and stuff
yeah so we're just teaching him like
whenever things arise so even like with
uh
with swimming like we're teaching him
how to float on his back and then so
we'll go we'll count to ten we'll count
to
ten together so he's like one two so
we're just trying to integrate things
into his play
so it doesn't feel so like school does
he know that he's learning when you're
trying to teach him stuff and he's like
all right you're sucking the fun out of
it
um he doesn't he just he just like
learns it
that's tight you're trying to slip in
like other strong lessons
huh you try to slip in strong lessons
like like cards gonna be like one
two do you know what momentum is
i'm glad you went there you know because
that's kind of what we're doing with
this
acceleration but i even teach them like
chinese and stuff like that too like
well
passed by a basketball court i'm olan he
goes oh lancho
so he's like learning just like random
things that's so cute yeah that's
awesome
yeah those are the good old days when
they're young enough to not know that
they're learning
when they start learning and you have to
punch them well
never but but like for example with us
with our 12 year olds
anytime like he's just trying to relate
to us and just be like oh yeah you know
like this and this happened
and then we were like our freaking
parental oh things go up and we're like
moment to teach or lecture like it ends
up being a
lecture he's 12. he's been 12 for like
10 years i feel like
i thought he's been he's just turned 12
in january what the hell i feel like
when i moved here he was 12. it's been
10 years since january
yeah i think you met him when he was
like 10 years in january dude he was one
kid i feel like no
he was like six or seven i think when he
met you that's great anyway
so then yeah it ends up that
conversation ends up getting
into a lecture and then we see him being
all bored he's just like i already know
you're trying to teach me something so
we can't even teach them
but that's why like when they're young
it's the perfect time
to really incept them with a whole bunch
of good [ __ ] in there
and like teaching complicated um
things like momentum and they they're
spongebob's momentum they are sponges
dude especially at that age because
tycho's about to be three
pretty soon so i have a story here about
this mom
she's a mother too she has a
three-year-old and a two-year-old
and so her name is jessica so and she's
a board certificate corey marpaka
board-certified dermatologist she was
just bored
like he is right now you're all trying
to talk about education he's like
he's already checked out yeah i'm
learning too much right now i don't want
to learn i want to play
i feel 12.
[Laughter]
yeah why can't you be like my niece and
teach yourself
yeah so jessica here she like i said
she's a board-certified dermatologist
and so she just started doing these
really cute videos with play-doh where
she's
actually doing surgeries with her
three-year-old
that's so tight yeah like it's [ __ ]
wild she's like this is the posterior
side of the play
she is okay using anatomically correct
terminology you mean dorsal side
what is she teasing i have no idea what
the [ __ ] y'all saying
what a [ __ ] [ __ ] dude sorry that was
like karen
what kind of surgeries like boob jobs
nose jobs like carteroid
uh end directive she's like this is a
colonoscopy
she's a dermatologist what did she teach
they must be wrong
no i mean she still earned a medical
degree so
eczema so i'm gonna show you guys
a compilation of some of these videos
that she's posting on her facebook page
and uh her facebook page is the
breakfaster so
i was checking out her instagram and so
in the past she was doing more like
really
beautiful like art pieces of like
breakfast
and lunch and like for her then the
algorithm trashed her career huh you
have to switch it up she's like i have
to do some [ __ ] with my kid now yeah
she's like i gotta do something with my
kids now because the algorithm isn't
favoring food
yeah so i don't know what the thing is
actually i do know how she started doing
the surgeries because she said it was at
her three-year-old's curiosity at one
point
like asked her about something and then
they started like they went into this
rabbit hole
of search like searching and eventually
they ended up on
surgery videos and so it got to it got
so gory for her that she
ended up turning it off and then her
three-year-old's like mommy it's not
gross for me
you can close your eyes that's a you
take them to the doctor
which is a psychopath yeah dexter it's
because they can't tell yet
exactly well the kid's like oh it's not
gory for me the kid's getting
conditioned
too like gross or whatever a different
word three-year-old words
so here we go here's like a little whoa
so she created is that a ear mega
intricate
play-doh like layers of the human body
and teaches her three-year-old that's
pretty dumb
exactly she's like this is an abscess
it's so sick
daddy's what screwdriver oh
yeah that's really cool
that's a hell of work
wow
okay her kid's going to be way smarter
than mine i know i'm so excited for this
kid
to be
syringes and stuff that's something yeah
those kids smart dude
oh yeah well the parents dumb too though
okay their parents doing all the work
you have just like clamping
when we look inside there wow it looks
like that but that's
that and the kid's roasting that body at
the aroma it's like the fat
no it's the atheroma yeah appropriate
appropriate terminology nice and clean
inside now
kid's going to go to school the next day
can i see her at the roma
damn my mom's a genius
okay that's a creepy oh
because sometimes the kids don't know
yeah true
mommy i got two ears well that kid's so
the mom's so smart because like
she already had to start with the
problem and then build around it and she
knew what she needed to get to
to fix the problem at the end like
that's a good kid though
okay i could not like at three i would
just be like this
yeah she said like because she went at
his pace threw it somewhere right yeah
like she went at his pace and his
curiosity so that's how they landed to
this point that's not like a tiger mom
yeah we're just so so the kid
is actually interested yeah like mega
interest what is that
because if my mom busts that out i'll be
like yeah well because i mix our colors
together
at me at this age if that lady wanted to
teach me a plato i'd be like super
interested
yeah no because so like i said you guys
are the same intelligence
because he was saying i didn't know yeah
i'm learning with him
exactly no exactly i did in that video
doesn't check it out so
it on facebook there have been so many
people that
responded to this extremely positively
and even
medical students who said i just had to
take a test about this one thing
and because of your video i was able to
remember certain things about the human
anatomy so like
she's helping a ton of people not just
her three-year-old how funny it would be
like you like you have something in your
neck like that
that plato did so you have to go get
surgery but you walk in the doctor's
office and the doctor is like watching
this video with the play-doh
everybody wacky just shuts it off that
turns right he's like oh i thought
you're gonna go the other way it's like
you need a surgery you're walking as a
kid
i'm saying don't worry i know i've seen
this before with those plastic scissors
she goes yeah can i have your hair
that's crazy so you know how i mentioned
she also has a two-year-old
so she has a two-year-old daughter she's
a heart surgeon and so the daughter was
like
how come my brother gets to do these
videos like you know like she wanted to
also learn
and so she ended up doing videos like
she's smart too she knows
yeah like what she'll jealously like
though because she was trying because i
saw that one video with the two-year-old
and she was just trying to like
be patient trying to just let her
explore but then the little girl just
like
that's me she should be on mousus there
we go that's what she's that's her
speed right how probably some shoulders
right here showing them off
oh this one's a doctor he's five years
old uh this one's using homosexuals
she's a physical therapist all right oh
wow the other one's a physical therapist
there we go
there we go oh yeah you can't say
masseuse anymore it's also
it's massage therapist i heard oh right
that's true i didn't know
my parents used to own a massage envy
and they were like massage therapists
don't ever call them a suicidal
light like a don't you have to go to
school to become a massage therapist
yeah i think so i think it's kind of
like
that's what the masseuse is yes no the
no license like flight attendant exactly
yeah you don't say stewardess you say
flight attendant yeah what's wrong with
stewardess
you don't say night like female oh oh
okay we want to be called the male
stewardess
steward do you say male nurse anymore is
that just
nurse you're supposed to just say nurse
he calls this because nurse is not
female right so like stewardess
yeah he's like supposed to be female or
like masseuse
do you say like man or woman anymore or
do you say like human beings anymore
i don't know masseuse was it was
gendered
less professional than a massage
therapist is all it is that's not the
gender
you saw what casey just said and he said
wussy's
stupid ass yeah well
so our hookers
yeah what's the proper way to say that
they're they're uh they're they're sex
workers they're sex workers not penile
therapists
they're sex women no penile therapist is
more like you have to have a degree for
that
do you to be a therapist from where is
it
from penile oh okay penile university
you guys are such boys sorry um first of
all it's
boy or what no it didn't work i was
trying to go with stewardess but
you couldn't say first of all it's man
you play with a different version of
boys
that's funny anyway so yeah these videos
have been super helpful for a lot of
people because they're
saying that even for squeamish grown-ups
they have been just really curious about
procedures so they're able to consume
her content like
i love this [ __ ] i'm so i hope way more
people end up doing
stuff like this because it's so
educational but not gory but
but also very accurate i don't know can
she teach her son about taxes
and we watch that video i want to learn
that one plato yeah
yeah cause that would help me so much
yeah you get all the play-doh like this
right he put it
and you go so this is all the money made
this is how much the government takes
so you work this hard for this oh this
is your money yours okay
but you can't spend it she's all like
she gets a lighter she's like you see
this
this is what happens when you live in
california
and that's why elon and joe rogan's
[Music]
leaving
foreign